everybody thanks for coming to our final
super final last workshop last day last
afternoon session
so the first of our two talks is and a
brother who unfortunately I have to make
this to the r-la all by yourself
thanks thanks everybody for coming out
and Leah this week I was giving a
mathematics of machine learning in
summer school at the University of
Washington and I think it's a really
exciting time to be doing really I was
just saying to Peter I think it's a it
was amazing to see that there was about
a hundred and fifty people at the
theoretical RL session of ICML so maybe
I could just do a quick show of hands
who who was here on Tuesday when there
was a wonderful plethora of RL talks
okay so a number of you are probably are
all enthusiasts but I think I find it
always really motivating to think about
the past and where we're coming from and
it's a pretty lovely quote from a Stuart
Russell who is the Stuart Russell and
Peter nor makes book where they talk
about Aristotle be me one of the first
people to talk specifically about
sequential decision making
the idea of a doctor reasoning about the
final state they want to get to the
patient and then doing sort of
eventually it's sort of backward
chaining from that final desired state
towards the series of actions that need
to be done and now we might call that
something like dynamic programming and
in fact about 2,000 years after this
this sort of vision was realized by a
new assignment to amazing researchers so
I think it's incredible to think about
how long we've been struggling with the
issue of how to make decisions under
uncertainty and of course in many cases
were learning to do this we don't have a
model of the world where we're unsure
about how to do this and this is
something that kids start to do from the
very beginning but I think that we only
really started to see this formalized in
kind of the 1940s nineteen 1930s to the
1940s as the first time people started
to think about multi armed bandits and
reinforcement learning and I really
think that sort of it was only in the
1980s that we started to think about
reinforcement learning and the way that
right now of course there's been a lot
of amazing work in the controlls
community but as we've entered the last
decade people I think it's really a
completely new era of reinforcement
learning and probably everybody here is
familiar with these types of results
that are really outstanding and maybe
not for anybody in this room but
certainly when I talk to some of my
colleagues even just further away in
other aspects of computer science and
certainly when I talk to my colleagues
that are not computer scientists and I
tell them that I'm doing reinforcement
learning they have some questions so
they might have heard of the go result
and I love this visualization from deep
mind of thinking about the incredible
branching factor of the decisions people
that have heard about this result
naturally say if we can do this if we
can do something that was such an
enormous intellectual feat wasn't
proposed to be finished for at least
another ten years well what are you
doing it's reinforcement learning solved
and how are you continue to publish
papers
and I when I think about the work that
we're doing in my lab and many other
labs I think about the parallel legacy
of reinforcement learning to try to
benefit people and so really from the
very beginning of when people started
thinking about artificial intelligence
and reinforcement learning they started
to think about how could it be used to
augment people in addition to how could
we achieve human-level or replacement
and in a lot of my work I think about
the technical challenges that come up
when we think about specifically systems
that are going to interact with people
and augment people we think about go or
if we think about robotics we typically
think of there being a simulator of the
domain having access to enormous amounts
of data to train with and that we can
always try out a new strategy without a
lot of harm so there's as long as we
eventually learn a really good go player
than that's sufficient it in the context
of people so far we don't have good
simulators of human physiology of
behavior or learning and gathering real
data involves impacting real people and
so that introduces sort of the the main
focus of what I think about in in my
with my students and with my lab which
is how do we think about techniques to
minimize and understand what data is
needed to learn to make and I think this
is not only sort of a foundational quest
within reinforcement learning but I also
think that it has this key implication
which is if we can learn to make
decisions faster we can need less data
then more people can benefit because if
I think about sort of making something
like a tutoring system if my tutoring
system needs eight billion data points
to learn well then there's nobody left
to benefit from my amazing tutoring
system so what I'm gonna do today is
talk mostly about a question I've been
really excited about for the last five
years which is counterfactual or bat
reinforcement learning and then if
there's time I'll go to the end but I
sort of switch the order of this because
I want to make sure to get to this start
so this is probably going to be familiar
to everybody but just in terms of
notation and in case there's only
control theorists I'll make sure to say
that I'm going to use s for state I
we're gonna have a decision policy which
is a mapping from States to actions will
take actions in the environment will see
rewards and we'll think of there being
value functions which are the sum of
immediate rewards plus discounted sum of
future rewards and we're gonna care
about finding the optimal value function
and we're gonna be interested in the
reinforcement learning setting where we
only observe this through samples or
experience together I'm gonna be really
interested at least in the most of the
talk today when we don't actually get to
gather this experience and my interest
to this comes from when I was
collaborating was Arne Popovich around
five years ago so we were starting to
collaborate together with some students
and this is the game refraction which
teaches students about fractions and so
the idea in this case is that the
students have access to different laser
beam splitters that they can use to fuel
a spaceship up here this game is made by
somewhere between a hundred to five
hundred thousand people and what we
wanted to figure out is how to help
people persist this is an optional
learning activity people can log on to
this they can go over to Facebook or
YouTube whenever they get bored and so
this has a high barrier in terms of
potentially losing people and we wanted
to think about decision strategies to
try to keep people engaged this is where
the reinforcement learning part comes in
so we want to think about sort of
conditioned on the past levels that they
were doing and their performance which
could be as simple as something like how
long they took to complete the previous
level what is the next level I give them
in order to keep them engaged so the
reward function here is gonna be how
long they continue how many activities
they do in this game and my state can be
anything my state could be something
really simple like this or it could be
the complete history prior activities
they've done it could be weird they're
clicking on the game it could be all
sorts of other features
and what we didn't want to do in this
case is we didn't want to do random
exploration this was an optional game
people talked about it if we were doing
things that were completely frustrating
to lots of people nobody would ever play
this game again but what we did have
access to was a limited data pool of
about 11,000 learners trajectories with
random actions essentially they got
random series of activities through here
and then we looked at how long they
persisted for so the goal in this case
was to learn a new policy that we
thought would help people persist for
life this was the first time I'd been
doing reinforcement learning for awhile
before this but this was the first time
I really thought about this issue of
sort of counterfactual or batch off
policy reinforces right before this I'd
been thinking a lot about exploration
and this is the case now where we have a
data set of n trajectories which are
gathered from a behavior policy however
most of this talk I'm going to assume
what that we know what this is in
practice we do not always know what this
is
I've been very interested in
observational health care records right
now and we don't know what that is for
physicians they don't tell us with
probability 0.9 I prescribe tylenol high
probability point two I do aspirin but
in the context of many robotics problems
and in our fractions problems we knew
this
so the question in this setting is how
do we use this data to make better
decisions and people are sometimes also
calling this sort of what-if reasoning
so we think about there being a series
of decisions that are made for an
individual and seeing some sort of
outcome variable at the end of this but
my question is as a new individual comes
in what should we do to maximize that
and this is a hard problem because data
is censored so just like in the
multi-armed bandit setting
I know multiple people here work on I we
can't tell what would have happened if
we took a different series of decisions
right now if you had decided to instead
go get coffee at one of the many fine
establishments nearby you never know how
wonderful your life would have been
under that particular trajectory we
can't see what would have happened for
the same individual if we do so that's
the first challenge and that comes up
even in the case of multi armed bandits
but I think the second really big
challenge in this case is generalization
in that even if we just have a discrete
set of actions if we're making a series
of choices then the number of possible
combinations of action sequences is
going to grow exponentially and it's
just gonna gonna be possible to try all
of those so historically we it the way
we normally deal with you know figuring
out what's the right thing to do for
high-stakes scenarios like clinical
trials is we do a randomized control
trial and then we just explore all the
conditions but the problem is is that's
not gonna scale very well as we start to
have lots of sequences of interactions
we think that in some cases the
sequences of interactions might be
really important for deciding what's the
rating
so I think it's been really exciting to
see that over the last year or two
there's a lot of excitement and growing
interest in the intersection between
causal imprints and machine they're
amazing literature tradition and in
causal reasoning for a long time and now
we're starting to see a lot of people
issues learning thinking about this
particularly and including in the deep
learning communities because people want
to think about building models that are
gonna generalize in some strong way so
in particular the problem that I'm
thinking about and started thinking
about motivated by this fractions
problem its batch counterfactual policy
optimization meaning that we want to
pick a decision policy that when we
deployed in the future is gonna do well
so one way we could maybe formalize this
is to think about us estimating the
value of a policy given an input data
set and we might want to be making some
sort of model selection over a policy
and given some different hypothesis
classes this is already um there's some
interesting differences compared to
supervised learning because the
hypothesis classes we pick could be
models like reward models and dynamics
models of the environment they could be
value function classes or they could be
policies so there's already some
different choices of what do we even
mean by the hypothesis base and then
there's an additional challenge which is
this question here is often referred to
as simply policy evaluation which is
someone gives you a policy and then you
want to know how good it is there's been
a lot of focus on this including by me
and my students but a couple years ago
we noticed that that's not sufficient
which other people have also observed
and and the challenge is that even if
you get an unbiased estimator here which
we often try to get then that can fail
in terms of some notion of fairness
fairness here I don't mean in the sort
of fairness accountability transparency
movement I mean in terms of us picking a
policy that has higher value at least 50
percent of the time if it's actually
better
and intuitively the reason for this is
just because of the bias-variance
tradeoff so by getting an unbiased value
estimator you are gonna have zero bias
but some of your policies much might
have very different variances than
others and so you can systematically
make wrong decisions so that made us
increasingly interested in whether or
not we could kind of more directly think
about the policy optimization question
and I would argue what we've been trying
to do over the last couple years and
there's still a huge amount to do is to
really try to do something like
structural risk minimization for
decision making
so often again when I talk to colleagues
of mine that are not in reinforcement
learning I explain doing this problem
they say well that's solved
we have cross-validation we have
structural risk minimization won't you
just divide your data into a train and
test set build some policy evaluate it
and then you're done
the problem is is that those types of
approaches require us to do some sort of
evaluation and often have some sort of
generalization guarantee early that's
maybe some function of like our
hypothesis classify story
and I just don't think we have that yet
I mean certainly there's been a number
of us that have been thinking about this
problem but I don't really think we're
there yet and I think that it's a really
exciting opportunity for us to try to
get there and I'll say a little bit
about some of the steps we're gonna
we've been doing it and try to get
towards that so particularly we can
think of this as sort of Venus split
between policy optimization policy
evaluation and getting error valves
ultimately we might not want those we
just want some sort of useful procedure
like cross-validation
I don't think many of you might be
familiar with this part but I just want
to highlight why this problem is so hard
even without the bound aspect and I
really like this recent figure from a
nature medicine paper from David sonntag
finale Josh Ebola is and some of their
groups and the challenges is that in
general for different decision policies
we're going to take by definition
different positions the problem is is
that those different decisions affect
not just the immediate reward but they
affect the next state you get into we
think about something like a healthcare
application let's say this is actually
our data set and then under our policy
for some threshold we would actually do
mechanical ventilation for everybody
well for a whole bunch of people in the
original dataset the doctors didn't do
that
now we reduce a lot of the number of
people that we have now let's say if
those people experience discomfort then
we our policy would prescribe some
amount of sedation so now we have an
even smaller cohort and in general the
amount of data that matches a particular
policy we might want to evaluate is
going to shrink contribute rate can
shrink even exponentially and so that
means that often the amount of data that
we have to try to do this optimization
or try to compare across different
policies is very small so the noise can
be very very large
so I think that the big challenge right
now is that there has been quite a lot
of progress on policy evaluation but
trying to combine this with policy
optimisation and air about that we're
still still a long ways to go and I'll
highlight why so I think some work kind
of that leverages things like important
sampling bounds provides unbiased
estimators but it typically ignores
anything about whether you've got our
structured policy class and it relies on
things like huff ting and other
concentrations inequalities which
typically require an enormous amount of
data so if you have sort of web-scale
data I think this can work well my
former postdoc Phil Thomas it done work
with Adobe and they could apply these
type of bounds there but for other cases
like for mobile health some of their
initial studies is like
a second case is to make sure that we
use some sort of kernel function or
average or approach but those typically
need number of samples that is
eventually a really important line of
work is on fitted queue iteration and I
think nan spoke earlier this week I
haven't seen this talk yet so I don't
know if he talked about this particular
line of work nan Jiang had a nice recent
paper in ICML as well as ISA news group
where they're providing new PDQ
iteration bounce the IQ iteration is
going to use a function approximation
estimate for this the problem is is that
often we require realizability for our
function class our true values and if
you don't have that then we normally end
up with a bound on kind of the inherent
Billman error and the problem with that
is that that's gonna depend on the MDP
we're in we don't know which MVP where a
and so they're not generally gonna be
evaluatable and the problem with it not
being evaluated will is that then
there's some challenges for Louis
election
I think that Lee Hong Lee was also here
earlier this week and he might have
talked about some of the new primal-dual
approaches for also furniture trying to
do value function estimation and
optimization I think those are also
really promising particularly from the
practical side but they tend to have
similar dependencies I don't think any
of these methods have really given us a
satisfying answer for can we have some
sort of error bound here that depends
into the environment should be so that
just like in supervised learning we can
make some assumptions of how good a
linear regression would be regardless of
whether we need to assume the world was
really linear regression so this is our
goal what we would really like to do is
to sort of have these nice strong
generalization guarantees on a policy
performance I think that's really hard
we're gonna move the goalposts
so the goalposts instead is gonna meet
what if we could just guarantee we find
it good in the class policy so much
weaker assumption that just say given
some policy class you have can you do
pretty well
but maybe that's gonna be a little bit
easier and then I'll get to a stronger
guarantee shortly so this is joint work
with agar well it led by Galu my
students also Heather's hormone and the
idea in this case is for policy gradient
methods we're gonna define a policy
class now we want to try to find the
best policy in that policy class but we
want to do it in the offline setting so
one thing I think policy gradient
methods are incredibly powerful one
thing that I find less satisfying about
them is that often you just throw away
your previous data and you gather more
data when you next from it and up till
now most the time leveraging the prior
data hasn't been all that hopeful and
one of the limitations is that when you
gather more data from the new policy
than you want to be able to incorporate
the fact that the distribution is state
connections you observe is different
there's some really nice recent work
from sort of three separate different
groups Simon ourian his students and his
collaborators and also mark Bell Amir
and some of his students recently all
developed methods which work on the
stationary distribution and this is
really nice because instead of having
sort of thinking about things at the
trajectory level there we're thinking
about things in terms of the stationary
distribution over state actions ratios
of how much that changes under policy
and so what we observed is that we could
use that most that's been done for
policy evaluation we can do that within
a policy approach results change like
sort of the policy gradient algorithm to
incorporate this new
this gives us some original guarantees
but perhaps more importantly it gives us
some really nice insights for using old
data so this is carp polls one of the
classic simple examples and what you can
see in the red here is the behavior
policy so the behavior policy is not
very good but it gives us enough
information that we can use it to learn
a much better policy so here we're
comparing most of the previous methods
for leveraging off policy data either
assuming you get access to additional
data or don't try to correct for some of
the state action distribution especially
what you can see here is the DAR method
up here does much better than those so
this is just policy gradient steps but
this is policy gradient steps all with
the same data so we're just giving a
Bachelor of data and we're gonna do the
really cool thing to me is that you can
see that even though the data the
performance of the the policy that you
have access to it's not very good you
could actually learn a policy that's
basically your optimal using that data
so why is that important well you can
imagine embedding this like Alec and I
were just talking about embedding this
within an online learning algorithm and
this just means that hopefully we can
squeeze a lot more information out of
our data but we can take bigger jumps so
instead of taking lots of small steps to
try to go from here to here we're
actually running this in the real
environment we could just take this data
from the real environment and already
jump up to there so that would be
awesome because I'm you would be way
less data to get to the same level
okay so this is exciting but what this
is doing is trying to converge to sort
of a local optima doing policy search
this still isn't getting at sort of the
stronger guarantees that I said we
wanted to try to get to so think about
if we can make it a little bit closer to
what we want so maybe instead of saying
we're still gonna do sort of a
restricted search but now we're actually
gonna try to guarantee we find the best
in the class policy so not just a good
policy in our class so maybe we'd want
to be able to do something like the
following where we have a best policy in
our class and then we have the policy
that we select and we want to have some
sort of regret bounds we have more and
more data depending on how complicated
your policy class is then we're gonna
get better and better at our ability to
select a good policy some sort of you
know good rate in terms of how much this
is gonna be a global guarantee within
our policy classes that have a local
width and so this is some work that I've
had the opportunity to do with shink
Whitney and Stefan wagger over at
Stanford and we basically have this sort
of result now for a particular type of
policy area and in particular the type
of policy learning we're doing in this
case is when to treat policies so as an
example of this you could imagine
something like HIV and you are not going
to start treatment until cd4 count a
measure of sickness is gonna drop below
a certain threshold at that point you're
gonna start the treatment
it's a little bit like optimal stopping
problems except for in addition when you
stop you're gonna get to decide amongst
one of a set of actions so like I have
some threshold for when to start
treating and when I treat I get to
decide amongst a set of things like some
decision on when I retire when I retire
I get to pick a month so it can be used
to represent things like this or another
form of kind of a linear threshold
policy would look something like this
maybe there's no time and some health
metric and you're either gonna turn the
treatment on or off this d-h covering
number you had on the previous slide was
that based on great question so the
cover we are going to be covering in
terms of if your data doesn't cover
you're only going to be with it with
respect to you so like for example it
may be the optimal thing for some people
is to do treatment five if you don't
ever try treatment five otherwise that
was a regular mean it was a lot of
covering over
okay so it's like what we expected
except oh this th-this is something
about so one thing so if so the key
question is how do we do this you know
what is the algorithm how do we
construct that off policy now this has
been an area that's been new to me
that's been really exciting to start
learning about so the first thing we do
is something that's quite common in
reinforcement learning and it's also
used in deep reinforcement learning
which is an advantage decomposition so
in our case we're thinking about the
difference in the expected value of
following a policy high vs. never acting
because we're doing when to stop and
treat and so we're gonna compare this to
never between the value of those
and both charm kakete and susan murphy
have both thought about this particular
advantage decomposition when we think
about what is the distribution those
states that you would reach and compare
the differences you start treating now
versus over the next time set and the
nice thing about this is that this looks
sort of like a bandit problem just do I
treat now or do I treat it the next time
step for a fixed thing that you would do
on the next and we're gonna end up doing
sort of estimating just this quantity
with a doubly robust estimator so try to
use W and W robust estimation statistics
to try to get a good estimate of this
and the interesting thing to me has been
about learning about this area of sort
of sorry semi-parametric statistics
which I'm only starting to learn about
where we treat some of these things that
we need to estimate as nuisance
parameters what we really care about is
this so that we can take PI star with
the max Delta what we're often gonna end
up doing is estimate value functions
we're gonna end up treating those as
well as the probability like our
behavior policy which you might not have
direct access to as nuisance parameters
that we can use to try to get at these
quantities really
the reason that I'm really excited about
this is that a lot of the problems that
I think about we have an enormous amount
of noise my students right now is
interning at a healthcare company and in
many of these scenarios compared to sort
of some of the beautiful signals an
Atari
it's really hard to see what is the
effect the action is having on the stage
so I'm increasingly interested in how
can we try to find methods that can
extract what is the signal that we get
from the actions themselves over and
above perhaps you know very complicated
stochastic processes
so we use this I did a couple different
sort of health inspired simulations and
we thought about the case where you
don't actually know the behavior policy
question which is those gets weird soon
when we have those variables but we
don't know what the pave your policy is
and then we wanted to look at linear
decision rules here what you can see is
that the graph didn't come up this is
essentially the amount of data we have
and this is regret so comparison of
policy and fitted Q iteration is a
really popular method
it's sort of an analogue to what's being
done in deep and you can see that it
doesn't do so well and the intuition for
that is that it's going to have low
variance but high bias because it's not
flexible enough it won't be able to
capture an optimal policy our method
continues to improve similar to an
important sampling method but it can do
and we can see these also in sort of a
second domain which but I think even
more importantly than this it can be
much more interpretable so I collaborate
with anomaly Joshi Velez's group a lot
as well and we think of trying to think
about how we could make the output of
these sorts of algorithms useful to
doctors and one of the things we think
about is how we would present
information about why we're decision
recommendations so our method because by
definition were constraining the policy
class to be simple so this case doesn't
have to be a linear threshold policy but
here it is this is the learn linear
threshold policy we'd say keep the
treatment on until you cross the
threshold and then turn it off you know
doctors could look at and then argue
about whether or not that's reasonable
or give us feedback of whether we
obsessed by it or function correctly but
the did queue iteration would do
something like this because it's not
constraining the policy to have any
particular structure so that means you
get these weird blips where it's like
okay well from right here I'd should
suddenly change my decision and then I
change it back or here and it's not very
smooth and it seems like it's a little
bit brittle and so if I was looking at
this as a doctor I'd say well why does
it suddenly make a slightly different
decision there that due to the fact you
don't have enough data or is that really
that there's some sort of complicated
function there where it's much better
I think that's one of the reasons also
that it's not only is it more tractable
to start thinking about policy class
estimation but also where it can be
beneficial because it's an easy place
for us to impose structure we've been
doing a lot of work on this spectrum
let's see you I think that there's a lot
of really exciting things to be done on
the context of policy optimisation
policy evaluation and parables and we're
also thinking about this for some other
perspectives to of how do we get their
balance that allow us to guarantees on
things before we deploy them to try to
provide more safe I just want to
highlight that there's a lot of other
really exciting work that's been done
out by a lot of my colleagues both in
terms of the theoretical we're only at
the very beginning and I think it's
really exciting to see that people the
number of people that are starting to
talk about counterfactual are well there
was a tutorial at UA I a few weeks ago
Suchi sorry who does a lot of really
amazing health care work is thinking
about this and I think one of the big
challenges too is that almost all of the
theoretical results require quite strong
assumptions including no confounding and
including no intersection intersection
meaning that the decisions we make for
one patient don't affect another patient
that's probably true there if we're
using this to save providing service
delivery drivers that's probably not
true talk to each other and so there's a
lot of things like a lot of really
interesting technical challenges that
come up when we want to think about
I've sort of sketched out a lot of the
hard things about doing this and why I
think we still have a long way to go but
I just want to highlight that I think
there's reason for hope so if we go back
to the example that I mentioned at the
beginning we wanted to think about given
11,000 learners trajectories could we
learn a policy that increases we did a
method that was basically sort of
important sampling based and what we
estimated is that our policy would be
improved persistence by 30% so that was
our estimate and so we wanted to
double-check that this estimate we
expected this to be a good estimate we
expected it to be but we wanted to
verify this and so we ran an experiment
with 2,000 additional users online and
what we found is that we increased by
about 30% 32% in fact I thought this was
a really exciting result for two reasons
one is that we actually improve students
persistence by a large amount which is
exciting about whether machine learning
can be helpful and identifying decision
strategies that we do human experts
can't always see in advance the second
is that we could have a method that
would predict the future before we did
it great question so the baseline policy
in this case was random and random was
actually better than the expert policy
they're using before so the data was
Galit gathered under a random policy and
so all of our performance was respected
but there was another policy that was
hand designed before and when we
evaluated that offline we expected it to
be worse than random which highlights
why that in some of these cases it's
really hard to write down a good like I
personally would not know you know if
someone placed a spaceship over here
first or used a third instead of a half
first is that bad or good what should I
do next and so in that case I think it
was really hard to know write down a
good decision policy and when we did
this verification experiment the expert
policy was worse than Man
so just kind of related to that I was
curious what is the typical
characterization that we're talking
about here that like did you even have
enough signal with a random policy great
question so one of the reasons you might
notice it with this and and so this was
one of our early works where we started
to think about this in this case the
horizon is pretty short it's an online
learning environment so people normally
play somewhere between 4 to 8 levels
very short horizon one of the reasons we
started getting really interested in all
of the sort of performance bounds is
that the variants journaling scales
exponentially with our eyes but in this
case we're for better or worse people
were playing for quite short numbers of
interactions it was feasible to use sort
of an important factor titania
so I have some other stuff on the
exploration side but I think I'm gonna
just conclude with that which is I think
that it's really exciting to think about
sort of what is the David we need to
learn to make good decisions in our
exploration work we've been thinking
about lower bounds on that case it's a
bit of an amount of data any agent human
artificial etc would need in order to
make good decisions and I think now
we're at the point where that problem is
sort of solved for the tabular case it's
a really nice work for my colleagues at
deep mind that closed this for the
regret bounds a couple years ago for
episodic tabular reinforcement learning
and recently we closed it for the pack
City so I think in this case we now have
a pretty good understanding of how much
data we need and how to explore in order
to get good data to make good decisions
and then I think also the second
question of how do we leverage any old
data that we have to try to make better
decisions there's a lot of excitement it
also of how can we combine between these
two both but gather better data and then
best use it in order to make decisions
[Applause]
I was curiously we were talking about
three work full treatment rules and
brought up setting parameters
concentrate if the main okay
like optimal experimental design and
things like that I think it's a super
interesting at so Freddie who didn't it
I was asked about given sort of my
mentioned if medical data have we done
any work on sort of optimal experimental
design I think it's a super interesting
and I feel like there's sort of optimal
experimental design there's dynamic
treatment regimes learning and none of
those communities talk to each other and
so actually one of my colleagues know a
Goodman is gonna run a seminar this fall
on optimal experimental design that's
Joey Porter's I'd love those I think the
communities between epidemiology
so you mentioned that one of these you
think people maybe even especially
Outsiders to work on our producing
something assumptions there a variety
that you thought up realizability and
maybe some of the conditions beyond the
policies in article to strike these
covering members maybe do you want to
say a few words about one of the other
favorites or one of your favorites how
much what I'm really interested
confounding so the confounding question
is that where there variables used to
make decisions so maybe when you're
doctor coat when your doctor sees you
they notice that like whatever eyes is
blue and one of your eyes is pink and
that means something really important
into whether you get Tylenol or aspirin
but that's not written down in your
electronic medical record system so then
when your policy is learning the key
challenge for why that's a problem or at
least the way I think of it is that you
don't have coverage it may be that like
the policy is gonna just prescribe
things which you would never do and so
we're gonna get wrong estimates there's
been some nice recent work from John du
cheese group and some of his colleagues
about how much confounding can affect
your estimators without treatment effect
estimation for a single decision
the reason I care about that a lot is
that I think if we could do that we
could better unlock observational help
better or worse I'm in America we have a
fairly strong legal culture and which
means the doctors have to have very good
documentation I also think that if we
could do better and I'll heal all those
those you might imagine that we really
would have all the features but I don't
think we're there quite yet so I think
that's one of the areas that I think
would be really great because practice
from this has been a big problem for us
for when we have existing datasets that
we want to try to evaluate our methods
on because unless there are randomized
control trial there might be confounding
could start to use
Frances journal question how do you see
the incorporation of game theory from
economic sciences in New York I think
that's really triggered yeah the
question is like how do how would you
use game theory there's a lot of
interesting different directions for
that particularly for the safety and
robustness colleagues of mine that who
during work on autonomous cars etc I
think and also the multi agent setting
itself no personally I think it's also
really interesting to think about the
operative case we talk about all of us
because you often have cases where like
in a cooperative way you don't pay
enough attention Tulsa's what they have
in there those I think from a robustness
and reliability that even there's a lot
of opportunity
let's think about it
[Applause]